George Zimbel, un photographe
montréalais qui est décédé à
l'âge de 93 ans.
- Now, sododody can call
the police on you
if you're taking a picture.
- Le penenenenenenenenenenenenec
les gens de la rue,
mais aussi des cririrités.
Son fils Matt est déterminé
à garder sa mémoire vivante.
MATT ZIMBEL,
- Il veut avoir l'intimacy.
Il veut avoir une connexion
avec le sujet.
Ça, c'est pour lui, ça,
c'est la plus importante chose.
c'est pas important.
- Né au Massachusetts,
orororge Zimbel amorce sa carrie
à New York, où il travaille
pour des journaux et des revues.
♪ ♪ r r r r r r r r r r r r r re
célèbre photo de Marilyn Monroe,
alors en tourndududu film
"Sept ans de réflexion".
GEOFFREY JAMES, photographe
et ami de George Zimbeupupupupup
plus que ça. Et vraiment,
ce qui, pour moi,
important, c'est son travail
personnel. Il avait un regard
très rapide,
- Installé au Canada
il adopte Montréal au début
des années 80.
Dans son portfolio : des
photographies de personnalités
John F. Kennedy.
CLAUDE GOSSELIN, Centre in
d'art contemporain de Montréal
- Il les a pris dans
où ils étaient sur tel lieu.
Il est allé cherchphphphphoto.
Il réussissait à joindre
l'intime et le public.
ont été présentées entre autres
à New Yststststston et Tokyo.
Le Musée des beaux-arts
une exposition en 2015.
L'année suivante,
le documentaire "Zimbelism",ndnd
hommage à ce grand humaniste.
Il avait beaucoup de respect
pour les gesesesesessayait
de transmettre leur... leur vie.
- Fidèle à son amour pour
les images inoubliables,
à l'âge de 93 ans en écoutantpos
Glenn Gould jouer Bach.
(Glenn Gould au piano : urururu)
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréa